pourtant trader
alors tu compteras extraits d'émissions
télé réalité tu me disent tu valides ou
pas tu ne gâche chaque fois validé pas
validé on vous a fait une petite compil
de ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
dans la villa les marseillais et les
anges regarde aujourd'hui je t'invite à
la chabotterie toile à sa montre et
enfin deux femmes décident d'amener des
copains et des copines à l'achat
motrices
bush que ton deux pas du tout en créant
du coup je pense que dans la tête la
guerre est à mettre les choses à plat
écoutez je pense qu'on a longtemps agi
versée avec les originaux ning moi je
pense que les chauffer la piscine
[Musique]
ça va être chaud retrouver deux comme il
ya une révolte à sion entre vous c'est
fou y'a pas d'armes de provence il n'y a
pas de quoi se venger contre x c'est
quand tu vas trop bête s'appelle m2
province donc ça se trouve qu'en
province mais dans un magasin d'en
acheter ici
[Musique]
la mayo d'accord et maire de proches
aidants
est-ce que tu pas du palais vraie vie
scolaire a été validé ou pas va l'image
valide pas valide pas pourquoi je n'ai
jamais regardé en fait ouais 7 7 7
gonfle sa te dit rien à l'art bien lieu
tu l'aurais fait toi ça c'était que tu
le taux resterait participer mais n'a
pas réussi dans la musique
non non jamais ouais tu voulais réussir
à tout prix tôt tu voulais faire d'abord
ta musique et après dire voilà si je
réussis réussi non je voulais réussir
chez pas par quels moyens après la
musique c'est devenu un peu ça met un
peu tombé dessus
parade entre guillemets savais tu aurais
jamais fait de la télé réalité tout ça
tu jamais alors deuxième truc la
victoire de l'om hier soir valider ou
pas validé a validé et et de boulogne on
va voir la célébration du but de mario
balotelli regarder
[Applaudissements]
moi il sait pourquoi ils sont contents
comme ça ma quatrième gros ça revient là
quoi va faire quoi quand il va être
premier mais ce matin paul s'est pas
prise de quoi tu es vraiment quoi dire
ils ont gagné un championnat
bah ouais mais là ça remonte sa commande
un gilles oui puis moi j'aime bien ce
qui fait balotelli il avait prévu un
grand enclos de marquer un but mais bon
ça fait partie du spectacle sportif on
peut avoir de paris attend d'avoir
marqué un but de son attaquant
tu pense qu'on va gagner contre
manchester là encore mercredi ou pas moi
de photos tu vas y voir le match non
mais je repars la whey pour par direct
ouais d'accord c'est du boulot moi
excusez nous annoncions passant je bosse
tous les jours on fait des chèques qui
toi tu veux c'est fait la troupe des
[ __ ]
cette année avec kylie ann m bape et
notamment regarder kidian comité content
tu me dis si bonne idée ou pas valide
on trace et faire des manifs
c'est très bien aussi
le public est évoqué aussi les témoins
croyab le mans les
les gens disent
les personnaliser comment aider et je
les remercie pour ça et c'est vraiment
une super journée
on peut dire maintenant vous êtes à bâle
en forêt
l'embrasement social vous regarderez
vous qu'il ya les vrais jeux s'est jeté
sur moi très fort qui émet dans les
[ __ ] houba houba jamais j'avais
pourquoi pas ce que regardent pas voilà
bien qui diane salopette là comme ça et
s'ils disent voilà tu peux rester comme
ça non même pour la bonne cause tirait
pas tu peux faire faire de bonnes causes
de mon côté d'accord ouais ouais enfin
atteint un record d'audience ont des dix
prochains l'année dernière ça fait 9
millions 700 mille 1 merci de votre
intervention